>>Tom Friedman: And it was really about this
issue of the competition between climate change
and poverty reduction. [pause] In your work
at the foundation, are you finding that competition?
Are you finding one is driving out the other
more particularly of late, and what are you
going to do about it?
>>Thanks Tom. Tom, thanks for doing this.
>> Tom Friedman: My pleasure.
>> Means a lot to all of us. At the morning
talk it was almost like it was set up between
Al and Donna Antipote's conversation. Climate
change versus poverty. The funds, the discussion,
the public concept. And it was all about a
gas, an atmospheric gas. But I thought it
was not about carbon dioxide, it was about
oxygen. Because it's true that climate change
takes all the oxygen out of the room, and
it takes all the momentum out of people who
spent their life committed to working against
poverty and it shouldn't be like that. Not
only are the poor in the developing world
the greatest victims of climate change, but
if we don't grow economic development in the
right way they will contribute as in China
and in India to climate change in a way that
we won't be able to bring it back. So, I can't
imagine a better statement. I heard President
Clinton say that the growing disparity between
rich and poor and the marginalization of poor
people, it is unequal, unfair, unstable and
unsustainable. And it contributes to insecurity
around the world. We need to be mindful of
all these things. You know, the good news
I think about our generation is that whether
we're ADD or we can parallel process, we've
got to be big enough and grown up enough to
be able to simultaneously handle more than
one threat. So what we're doing about it is,
we announce five initiatives, two of them
are on poverty. And..
>> Tom Friedman: Go through the five.
>> Go through the five?
>>Tom Friedman: Yeah , just real quickly
>> So taking from poverty first. I was in
Africa. Many of you were I recognize your
faces. Were at the TED conference. There was
this big fight between aide and trade, aide
and trade. But if you talk to poor people
in the developing world, they're not going
to say I want more aide, more foreign aid.
They say, I want a job; I want to be able
to feed my family, and care for my family.
I want government services that work, education
for my kids, health care, electrification,
water. So we decided that those were twin
halves of the problem of poverty and economic
development. So one of our initiatives is
to empower people, not just poor people, but
you know starting off with poor people in
the developing world. So that they know what
public services, government and other public
services, are available. And empower them
to take advantage, to avail of, and to have
access to these services. Governments are
not bad, but we have this illusion that third
world governments are corrupt and incompetent.
There's wonderful governments in the developing
world and sometimes they just don't have the
tools to deliver what they want to do. So
the other half is to try to help governments
develop those tools and that draws in Google's
technology and our information services. The
other initiative in the area of poverty is
job creation. And two thirds of all the jobs
in the United States are created by small
and medium sized enterprises. You'd think
it was the same in the developing world, it's
not. Less than fifteen percent of all the
jobs in the developing world are created by
small and medium sized enterprises. The bulk
of jobs now are created by these big, large
corporations, mostly extraction industry.
So if we can fire up the small and medium
sized entrepreneur, that's where all the jobs
will come from. We hope to be able to play
a role in that. In the area of health, and
in particularly the area of pandemics, and
in merging communicable diseases, there have
been three dozen new diseases that have jumped
from animals to humans in the last thirty
years. Any one of which under the wrong circumstances
could become pandemic. Or one of which already
has, HIV/AIDs, is a pandemic, and it jumped
from monkeys to humans. We worry about bird
flu and SARS, but there's also Ebola, basa
fever, marvric, you can chant them in a religious
way, all these diseases. You realize, something's
changed. And so what we're trying to do is
to fund early warning systems and increase
the availability of good response. And then
lastly, what we were talking about this morning,
our issues in energy and climate change, which
Larry and Surgay are going to talk more about.
On the one hand we, and I really appreciate
Al, you saying that r e less than c captures
the imagination of the problem. What Larry
said in the press conference, a little bit
wonkie, but you know, or a little nerdy, I
forgot what you said. It was something like
that. But it really captures the equation
exactly right. Until you can create utility
grade electricity from renewable energy at
a price cheaper than coal, but coal will be
burned. I lived in India ten years; every
lump of coal will be burned unless there's
a cheaper way to produce energy. So we're
really committed to that, and I'll let Larry
or Surgay or both, talk about what we're doing
inside of Google to mount an opportunity to
create our own one gig watt renewable energy
production facility. The flip of that equation
though is, as you said, we have to be able
to internalize the externalities of bad health
consequences of coal because the equation
only works when it's the right cost, the fully
loaded cost of coal and the fully loaded cost
of renewal. The last of our, our climate initiatives,
is to try to create a world in which not only
the coal stays in the ground but the oil stays
in the ground, the petroleum, the gasoline,
isn't consumed. And that really means electric
cars; it might mean temporarily, plug in hybrids.
But so long as you plug into a grid that is
mostly coal you do, you get some marginal
improvements but not substantial improvements.
If you have a grid which is green, and you
plug into a green grid, and the combination,
those two things really deal with almost fifty
percent of all of greenhouse gas emissions.
So I didn't mean to take so much time but
those are our five initiatives.
>>Tom Friedman: Terrific.. Larry let me start
with you, take us back to your own internal
conversations about R E less than C which
stands for renewable energy cheaper than coal.
Why you decided to go into the energy space,
it's a big move for Google. And what do you
think a company like Google could bring to
the goal of one giga watt of clean power,
enough to power San Francisco, that maybe
others haven't?
>>Larry: Yeah I think we were really luck
to be at the intersection of a bunch of different
things. Being in Silicon Valley we had lots
of friends and companies working in renewable
energy area. We also had this sort of relentless
demand for people on the internet to do things.
People searching, and email, and all those
things.
>>Tom Friedman: How did that manifest itself?
How did it you sort of, how did you notice
it?
>>Larry: Well we you know actually have to
buy computers to hold everybody's email and
everybody's searches and web and there's huge
numbers of computers and the energy to power
those. And you know we want Google to work.
You don't want to go to Google and say oh
sorry we're busy right now. [laughter] That
would be really bad so we're farced to be
very practical about that. And so we've had,
you know, we had a team going around building
data centers and finding energy, and so on,
and doing that worldwide, because we want
our service to be fast everywhere. And because
of that we really noticed we're getting you
know we have some facilities for example that
are close to dams and so on. But a lot of
times we're really displacing somebody else
who would use that energy. It's not that by
building a data center next to a dam, the
dam's already being used.
>>Tom Friedman: Right
>>Larry:Maybe you know there's not quite as
much transmission as there would have been
but it's not that that's such a green way
of doing it. And you know many places you
know you basically see that you know we would
see in buying a lot of electricity you know
where you get it cheaply it's from coal. And
you know the business side of our company
is saying well you know let's buy the cheap
electricity and make sure you know our bottom
line is good and all that. And we're kind
of looking, this isn't good right, computers
are using more and more electricity people
are doing more things with them and that's
the cost of your computing that's electricity
is going up as a percentage. It's actually
pretty significant it might even approach
the cost of computers themselves. And because
of that we said well why aren't we making
renewable energy cheaper than you can get
it from coal. That would be the easy decision
to make. Say we're gonna get it cheaply and
it's going to be green. And there's tons of
start ups in the space, we invested in some,
we had friends in many different ones. And
the problem we had is that all the start ups,
they can basically have an incredible business
making electricity at 10 cents a kilowatt
hour. And the reason is there's tremendous
demand for renewable energy. We would buy
it at a higher price but you know, you're
not gonna fundamentally change the game unless
it's cheaper than coal. And the problem for
a start up, you know they're looking at well
we wanna succeed and we can make it at 10
cents and succeed but we really wanna make
it at 3 cents to really change the world.
And we want those projects that could be 3
cents to start right now. And we're willing
to take you know the risks on those things
and obviously if you succeed in one of those
things you're going to have a great business.
But it's very rational for start ups to say
we're not going to take that risk we're going
to you know produce it at the 10 cents and
we're gonna have a great business and you
know we want our business to grow slowly and
our primary goal is not to fix that world.
Where as we have a little bit of luxury of
driving some of those products forward. So
I think we saw that there wasn't enough investment
in some of those things. And we also saw,
we talked to enough people that you know if
you really push the start up and the people
who are really smart on this thing, you say
well do you guys have a way of doing it at
3 cents. They say yeah we do, it's a little
bit modestly higher risk. But we have a clear
path to get there and you're like well why
don't we get going on that now, what do you
need? You know you get some people and a little
bit of money an so on. That's relatively modest
resource.
>>Tom Friedman: Surgay tell us a little bit
about where the initiative is right now? Are
you exploring different clean power alternatives?
Which ones attract you? Sort of where are
they? And what can Google bring to this that
an Exxon Mobile or Chevron can't?
>>Surgay: Well, just first off, where we are
right now. We highlighted three areas of renewable
energy that we thought would be good initial
focuses. Solar thermal, also deep geothermal
and [pause] good one, high altitude winds.
I should clarify specifically.
>>Tom Friedman: Why those three? As you winded
them down what..
>>Surgay: We were looking at the options around
at the time. I think there are potentially
a few others that could make the cut. If I
had to add one I would say photolotaeics.
But [pause] I think these are three that are
known into the renewable energy community,
but not broadly kind of thought about, well
understood. And currently for example, if
you look at wind power, the wind mills are
on par with colt today other intermittent
power you know one can't always rely on to
be there. But they are pretty good. We think
that it can be even cheaper by using high
altitude winds. And we highlighted one company
that we're working with call McCotney, they
use kites at potentially high altitudes to
generate and you know kites much cheaper to
make than big metal wind mills. So that's
a really interesting one. If you imagine getting
power that cheap, I mean that could be substantially
cheaper than coal. The other one solar thermal
is pretty well known, I mean you already see
these things with the big parabolic trenches
and the solar towers an what not. And it's
something that it just seems like there's
just a little bit of really basic just engineering
and development to make that be really cheap.
I mean there's no inherit barrier in the way
if you kind of you know you just need so much
mirrored surface and you can kind of do the
math. And the existing companies, the situation
that Larry said, you know they feel that if
they can produce at 10 cents which they take
the more conservative engineering route, they'll
still have a great business. We want to push
them a little bit more saying you know we're
willing to risk these maybe being not you
know not quite as 100 percent guaranteed to
pan out but we want to bring it down to 3
cents or something like that.
>>Tom Friedman: So just to technically how
you're doing it. You found a stable of companies
in these different areas and you've invested
in them?
>>Surgay: We have done investment in both
solar thermal as well as the high altitude
wind. We think that we should have some of
these things going on in house. We don't have
the in house research going on yet but we
are hiring in those areas. And deep geothermal
is actually another example of one because
if you look at Iceland or something like that,
in those areas that have that that works pretty
well for them. That's not necessarily you
know dirt cheap, I guess it's kind of dirt
cheap. Literally.
[laughter]
But it's anyway there's reason to believe
that if you go really deep and actually take
advantage of the technology that the dirty
industries take in terms of drilling and what
not that you can actually have geothermal
power be cheap and available almost everywhere
around the world. And that's really exciting,
that's a little bit further off. This is where
you don't really see start ups because it
requires more fundamental research.
>>Larry:A gentleman from Ireland I think is
here, they have 400 megawatts of geothermal
I think they own so there's a lot of great
work going on in those areas.
>>Tom Friedman: Larry what, Larry Page. Two
questions. One is, what is it, you guys have
been an amazing innovation company in the
area of search, what's the difference between
doing innovation in something like search,
bits and bytes, and doing innovation in something
like energy which is atoms, molecules? In
terms of being able to really do this kind
of breakthrough innovation. What's the difference
in working in these two areas?
[pause] [laughter]
>>Larry Page: I mean I don't find it to be
that different, we've had a fair amount of
work that's going on just making our data
centers efficient and actually a lot of the
people and knowledge we've had in pursuing
some of the energy related things are those
people. We're basically borrowing those people
a little bit from their day jobs and hopefully
Google will still answer your query. [laughter]
We've had just wonderful people in those areas.
I think you know what you need are people
who are willing to take a new way of doing
things and so on and who know enough about
the area to make some progress.
>>Tom Friedmand:What's been the reaction of
the energy companies? The Exxon mobiles, suddenly
they wake up one morning, they read the paper
that Google's going into the energy business.
And these are companies that are historically,
Al Gore and I were talking about this on the
way over, you know they're expert at pushing
things into the future and seems like you
guys want to claim the future now as opposed
to always keeping the future just ten years
out you know. What's been their reaction?
>>Surgay:I haven't talked to many of them,
I would suspect that their reaction is different
depending on which one. Like Exxon I don't
know would be the same as BP for example.
But some of these companies like BP are certainly
very interested in investing in these green
technologies. I think we have a little bit
of benefit that we don't have an existing
business that you know we're worried about
cannibalizing or anything like that. We bring
that to the table. I do want to highlight
one important difference between doing web
search and things like that and the energy
business, or at least web search when we started
it. Right now, it you want to prove a success
in energy, there's a certain scale you have
to achieve. Otherwise you can't demonstrate
the cost effectiveness of your product. And
that probably means putting in you know a
hundred million dollar plants or something
like that. And there's a big bet at some point
that you have to make and it takes a lot of
capital. And that's, we feel that this maturation,
or a company, that we have a fair amount of
capital and we're willing to probably be riskier
with it than other companies. Like we can
take a chance on a data center. I think that
puts us in position to do things that other
companies wouldn't.
>>Tom Friedman: I'm gonna get to that Larry
in a second. But I propose that Larry Page,
what's been the reaction of your share holders?
>>Larry Page: I mean I think it's been fine.
I think that westated, we stated, that we
would make investments, capital investments
and hundreds of millions of dollars that would
be, that would generate positive returns.
And I think we said, just what Surgay just
said, we take some more risk in those but
it would be modest and we expect them to net
out positive. We're already doing that in
the course of building out our infrastrusture
in data centers and so on. So I think that
reaction was fine. In terms of hiring people
and really getting these projects going, I
mean, those are, you know, if we can hire
a thousand people that are really excited
about doing this we would. But we're not going
to find those people.
>>Tom Friedman:Very brilliant. One of the
things we talked about at the morning session
is, I've always had this feeling that it's
much more important to change your leaders
than your light bulbs. Because leaders write
rules, rules shape markets, markets give you
scale. But one of the problems we're had,
you almost couldn't make this up. People don't
realize because it was actually badly reported.
We just passed an energy bill where we threw
out the incentives or we did not include the
incentives in wind or solar, and we maintained
those in oil, gas, and coal. Nick Romney just
won a Michigan primary, the republican party,
by promising to get rid of the mileage standards
just passed by congress. That is dumb as we
want to be, you could not make that up, but
we just did that. [Applause] Now how do you
[pause] succeed in this space without taking
(pardon the editorializing) but I read the
column now and I had to get it out you know
[laughter] Can you succeed in this space,
I'm interested in all three of you, without
taking more of a political position? [pause]
>>So, what do they do in law? They say I'd
like to incorporate by reference his comments.
[laughter] I'm accused often of being, maybe,
a little rosy eyed or rosy glasses, whatever
the expression is. Where's Donna to help me?
The people who have fought against [pause]
protecting us against climate change, a very,
very small percentage of them are bad people.
It would be disingenuous if you didn't recognize
them. Very small percentage are bad people.
They have children or they have grandchildren.
Whether they call it earth stewardship or
they call it protecting their kinds from using,
they're good people. We have some how failed
to articulate in the most compelling way the
urgency of the moment. Let me just take the
moment to say, when we talked earlier about
the conflict between poverty and climate.
I think this is an extraordinarily sophisticated
audience. But you know, I had a conversation
with Mohammed Unis, he's been friends with
me for thirty years. Think of his whole body
of work, five million woman who have had loans,
all of them had paid it back because of micro
credit, moving into telephony. We had a deal
with him where the save a foundation will
do surgery on blind people and he'll give
a micro credit loan to people who are blind.
Bangladesh and the rest of the world had benefitted
from everything he's done. All of which will
be washed away if you have a sea rise of three
meters. So you can't separate the quest for
dignity and fight against poverty and climate
change. And I think that, so he gets it now,
Mohammed Unis gets it. People working in the
developing world get it. They know that while
they want to battle urgently for the hurt
that poor people feel today, you know, the
two million who died this year of malaria.
They also know that with climate change it
will be five or seven million. We have failed
to get that degree of awareness and understanding
in congress and in senate and in the political
leadership. It's our failure. We can't give
up on that. So the areas that we're taking
aim at, I guess, because you got to be focused.
We're very interested in internalizing the
extranalities, the negative help extranalities
of coal. When you dig for coal, you kill people.
Miners die. They get black lung disease, they
get other respiratory disease. They're children
and our children miss school, we miss work,
for respiratory disease caused by coal. You
only have to be in Beijing for a moment to
understand that. So the regulatory issues,
the policy issues, about how we truly, what's
the true costing for coal. It's not just the
marginal cost of extracting one lump of coal,
it's what does society pay for it. I liken
it to second hand smoking issue. And that's
where I think we can go.
>>Tom Friedman: How do we change, how do we
reframe the debate though? So you gave Al
Quota these numbers this morning, nearlyer
three thousand questions asked up til now
on the Sunday morning talk shows, and on all
the debates. And three on climate in this
election. And as Al said there were three
on UFOs. So climate and UFOs are now equal.
[laughter] Whare are we doing, what is Google
doing? What is the plan to reframe the debate?
>>Earlier I think Bono said this would be,
maybe Al said, this would be the first time
that public movement took place in order to
raise taxes in trade. I think it's much more
compelling to look at what happened with second
hand smoking. There was a time, how many of
you remember when all of the chief executive
officers of all the tobacco companies raised
their hand and said no it doesn't hurt, it
doesn't hurt anybody at all and I smoke it
all the time. You know we need to reframe
the debate. We need to understand the negative
consequences of the way in which we are developing
our world. And coal is a great example. And
that's a role that we can play. We can fund
research with credible researches who will
identify all the extranlities of coal. It
shouldn't be Google saying we don't like coal,
it should be here are the best researched
in the world and we're gonna give them grants
so they can cost that out. Those are the kinds
of things I think we can do. Far more affective
than going to Washington and saying we're
Google you got to stop digging for coal. That
is not going to necessarily going to have
the desired effect.
>>Tom Friedman: Ok. Larry, knowing what you
guys know now about the energy business. And
how we get to scale. We're going to have an
election, we're going to get a new president.
Afterpoe that issue. What do you think would
be the most helpful thing, in terms of your
own project, that the next president, him
or her, decides on day one around the energy
space. Which would be most helpful in getting
your energy scale?
>>Larry Page:I don't know the best possible
thing. One thing that I'm concerned about
is transmission and I'll just tell the whole
story. I went to the university of Michigan
in engineering, and like 20 years before I
got there they closed their power transmissions
school. They had a school that dealt with
high tension wires and power transmission
that was closed long, long before I got there.
And you know surprisingly that area hasn't
advanced that much. I'm pretty concerned,
what Surgay mentioned about wind is very true.
The cost of a windmill, the power is competitive
with coal now except for transmission and
the variability. If you have better transmission
that really helps you with the variability.
There's been studies that show, for example,
Europe, they get 90 percent of their energy
from wind at a cost equal to coal. 90 percent
just from wind, at the same cost as coal,
if they have better transmission.. It's kind
of terrible that there's nobody working in
it as far as I can tell, or very, very few
people. And even if we did have the technologies
that were better for the transmissions, the
ones we have are probably good enough to solve
Europe's energy needs. But the odds that they'll
get deployed across a wide area like that
are probably close to zero without somebody
like a U.S. president, or somebody powerful
saying we're gonna build really good transmission
so that we can have better renewable energy
and solve some of these problems.
>>Tom Friedman:Kind of an interstate highway
system for the grid.
>>Larry Page:Yeah right now you know if you
order a transformer 30 years is an expedited
delivery. We know that because we've ordered
transformers. So I think you know in that
kind of environment, we're not going to see
very fast progress resolving these energy
issues. So I say transmission. We should always
just assume that we're gonna need better transmission.
It would be nice to use more energy than we
use now and having it be renewable. You know
we're not going to get any of those things
unless we have better transmissions and that's
gotta be a governmental issue.
>>Tom Friedman: Surgay, other than transmission,
what would be yours? What do you think the
next president could do that would be less
selfish?
>>Surgay: I think that we want to be on an
equal playing field with renewable and coal
and dirty energy. I think people kind of under
appreciate that right now and think wow all
the subsidies and taxes on dirty energys.
But the situation right now is very opposite
of that. If you just look at, Larry mentioned,
the pulmonary disease effects of coal, not
to mention the particulate of a lot of our
transportation. If you look at the Iraq war,
which whether you want to believe that the
U.S. is in there for oil or not. Certainly
the reason that Saddam had all that military
might was because of that oil money that we
paid. If you look at things like the cost
you put on renewables, the tariffs on Brazilian
ethanol right now. Because I would today,
sure I'd run my car on Brazilian sugar cane
ethanol, but the tariffs make it prohibited.
Even though it's the equivalent of 30-40 dollars
a barrel in Brazil today. I have friends who
have electric car companies and if you look
up the regulatory hurdles they have to go
through to get their cars on the road , all
the crash testing and what not. It's true
that car companies do all the crash testing
on their gas cars, but they don't on the motorcycles.
And you know the motorcycles are unsafe, so
why not, a budding young company can sell
a few hundred electric vehicles prior having
to go through all of that. Which may very
well be very safe. And also none of these
car companies are forced to consider the safety
of the people that they hit. It's kind of
a funny thing. I also having, we've installed
a lot of solar capacity at our campus.
>>Tom Friedman: Talk about that a little bit.
What you guys have done. And what you've learned
from your own experiences.
>>Surgay: I think we're up to 1.6 megawatts
or something like that now. We installed them
on the roofs of our building as well as we
built car ports and things like that. It's
been great. It creates shade, it reduces our
power costs, it's been a good investment.
But there were a lot of hurdles. And most
of the hurdles aren't technical, they're not
financial, they're just regulatory. You know
by the time you got all the permits to do
this that and the other. I don't think these
are people conspiring against clean technology,
it's just by the time you ad up all the federal,
state, local, government zoning, planing what
not, it adds up to a really big burden. Where
as if you use status quo technology, just
plug me into the grid, you don't have to do
anything, somebody just shows up. A friend
of mine recently installed a fiber to his
office building, and had to cross a small
creek so they had to put up a post. All these
people showed up and they had to verify if
it would withstand a 200 mile per hour wind
and what not. And the guy who erected it,
who normally puts it up for the power company
there, PGNE, said oh PGNE doesn't really have
to listen to any of those regulations, I just
put up a pole, don't have to go through any
of that. So there's just all of these hidden
barriers to clean energy today that don't
exist for dirty energy that's just the truth
of the world as it stands today.
>>Tom Friedman: Larry Page, one of the things
that Google is trying to do is unlock ownership
in the world as it is in overcoming poverty.
A lot of people have taken a crack at that
and it failed. What do you think you guys
could bring, or are bringing to that initiative
that might make it work where others have
failed?
>>Larry Page: well I think that the problems
that you have left in the developing world
are the really, really hard ones. I try to
take a lot of vacation time and travel around
there to really understand kind of understnad
what's really going on. And there's been already
tremendous work by many different people,
a lot of which are in this room. So I think
that we're going to try to do something, something
more. We've been running things like business
plan competitions, which I've seen personally
some of the works of. And I think the things
that I've seen that have been successful in
these areas aren't like massive amounts of
labor, but a very careful, kind os seeded
attempt to generate a little bit of knowledge
in local people. Like you should have a business
plan or you should think about what you're
going to do, then compete about it and talk
about it and learn about how to do that.
>>Tom Friedman: Talk about that, you started
a competition around business plans. Talk
about that a little bit.
>>Larry Page: I mean that's basically it,
you just have local entrepreneurs, you have
a big event, you give out a prize, a little
bit of money for the winner which gets the
winner ability to get funding and all those
things. It's just that whole mechanism, the
Silicon valley it's just what people do for
breakfast. They know how to do that, and in
Kenya or somewhere, they've never seen that
before. But once you get that started and
you get a community around, you get a few
hundred people involved first, then you get
thousands and so on. I think that's how you
are going to make progress, with local people.
And there's some idea that makes sense there
and really just growing that and making it
happen. I do think that having a lot of enterprise,
I mean there's a lot of things going on in
these places. But having a little bit of organized
enterprise having some of these things that
we know how to do just getting that idea into
people's heads is really important. You go
to these places and they don't have any debt
financing. I was in Ghana for example recently
and they don't have any debt financing for
houses really. And you're like well no wonder
it's hard for people to buy house. There's
no money for people to buy a house. You can't
secure it. We've discovered that's an important
thing. And somehow just getting that idea.
And the people there are very capable and
they can really run with those things once
people know about that.
>>Tom Friedman: when you are made aware of
a problem like that do you call up Larry and
say hey is there some way we can get financing
to local banks, or start our own? What do
you do with an idea like that?
>>Larry Page:I think we just try to talk about
them.. It's not, I think again, these are
the problems that are really hard that haven't
been solved yet and a lot of people haven't
been working on them. So there's usually 10
different things standing in your way. You
don't' have the body of law. The way they
do land ownership there, or a lot of these
countries you don't really know who owns the
land or you don't have clear titles. It's
hard to have that based on, so you just run
until you. The reason why it's not solved
it because there's 10 things that need to
be done. It doesn't mean you shouldn't try
to do those things.
>>Tom Friedman: Surgay, talk about what you've
learned in China and India energy space. You
obviously compete in China in the field of
search. What do you see there that excites
you or not about in the energy field?
Surgay: well I think primarily in China what
it stretched out about the energy space, the
number of coal plants that are going up there.
That's gonna be a really big challenge. I
think it is important for us to solve the
problem in the U.S. first ahead of pushing
the developing countries. But I do think that
we need to do it quickly before it's too late
for those other countries. And I think there's
a lot of reason for hope there too. If I drift
a little bit further to the field to Bhutan
which my wife and I visited a year and a half
ago. There's treks there where you hike up,
you know you go really high and get altitude
sickness. You're up in the middle of nowhere.
And the only people you run into are these
Yak Crickers. They don't really have anything,
they just have old tarp which they put over
a few rocks, they have their yak which are
wondering around far away. They only had one
piece of technology, well two, they had a
solar cell and an LED light. And it's a most
amazing thing.
Tom Friedman: And a battery also, that's related.
[laughter]
>>Surgay: Anyway you walk around, you're in
a really remote part of the world, kind of
in the sky and that's what they have there.
And it makes a lot of sense. First they have
a legal system where they are trying to prevent
deforestation so people can't just chop down
trees to make fire. And they do take some
and they use that for cooking. But they don't
use that just for their night light that they
need. And it turns out to be really, even
though for them I'm sure it's expensive to
buy solar cell, it's still really cheap compared
to the alternatives. And I think that makes
sense in a lot of places around the world.
Africa for example, where you don't have the
transmission lines, you don't' have great
roads to transport the diesel fuel. Not to
mention it's 100 dollars a barrel now anyway.
All these places, even at today's photolataeic
prices, it make a lot of sense to install
photolataeics. And I think you're going to
see that trend accelerate. Because this technology
has become cheaper more ambiguous and nothing
has been improving in the dirty space.
>>Tom Friedmand: Do you notice, in terms of
Google trends, if you've looked at this, or
if you can, in terms of what are people searching
for in terms of solutions. Climate change,
energy, clean energy, solar. Do you see anything
showing up there in Google trends at all
>>Larry Page: I haven't really looked at that.
I think people are definitely much more aware
of these things and it's hard for every day
people to know what to do. I mean you have
to compact fluorescent and so on. But I do
think a lot of the changes that need to get
made are the bigger issues, transmission and
bringing down costs, and all those things.
>>Tom Friedmand: I want to open up the floor,
we have so many...